that's an interesting question and no I
you know I loved it from the moment I
got there and one of the things there
are lots of young people in labs there
if you talk to many people who are in
science you'll find out that they were
in the lab from a very young age we had
a colleague visiting from the messages
general hospital a couple of weeks ago
and he was you know he said he would
started in the lab at 16 and I though I
was the youngest person one of the
wonderful things was I was treated just
like anybody else I was expected to do
my work and I did it and it was included
in the discussions and mostly I just
listened which isn't my nature but at
that point I was smart enough to know I
didn't really have much to contribute
but as I began to have things to
contribute I was allowed to and it's one
of the lovely dynamics of even now how
labs work you know we have young people
coming right out of college who work is
research assistants for us with us for a
couple of years before they go to
medical school or grad school and their
members in the lab they're expected to
attend lab meeting they're expected to
read the papers and it's really in many
ways an apprenticeship and I think it's
not perceived so much by by the outside
world of that sort of apprenticeship
mentorship dynamic and we now you know
there were lots of us sort of you know
in various labs at the University who
had just come there one way or the other
I guess because of the holiday lecture
series you know that must have been a
way of attracting people as long as it
existed but there is now a formal
program so we have high school students
who come and they spend the summer with
us and they do a project and they're
expected to write it up and it's I think
it's a wonderful introduction because i
do think one of the great challenges
still is how you teach science in its in
with its dynamism and you know the
aspects of discovery in a regular
academic environment
I think it's very hard
you